you did you play football in uh high
school yeah high school and college
where'd you play in college and just
school in virginia where ain't none
what's your team falcons
how are you feeling that's tough how are
you feeling with mariota yesterday is it
mariota it's mariota and we got rid of
ritter um ritter
someone you drafted yeah he just came in
i feel like he went to cincinnati they
did calvin really dirty or
or
i mean
why why let me ask you why you said it
first
he gambled on a game that he had i mean
he shouldn't have gambled on the game
but he got suspended for a year a whole
year and deshawn watson's out here
getting habitual rub downs
and got six six games
does the nfl hate women
can't say that
think about ray rice kareem hunt
kareem hunt ezekiel elliott all those
[ __ ] played like uh
he would know ezekiel elliot's [ __ ] was
what
minimal
i got calvin ridley bet on a game
and it wasn't even i don't think it was
like a anything crazy
yeah a whole year bruh
[ __ ] up my fantasy [ __ ] bro
oh that's your beef
let's get to you play the root of it do
you play fantasy football i did it the
first time last year uh
i think i don't know if i'm a good gm i
would be a better coach i thought i'd be
good at it because i know personnel and
players and [ __ ] but that's more of
about like it takes up a lot of time i
couldn't do it so i lost out of them
what was the draft like did you have an
in-person draft because because my
favorite part
that's fallen [ __ ] the best part about
fantasy football is when you get
together with your friends
and you just say just demeaning things
to them
cancelable things even you know
while you're you know in the same room
you got the [ __ ] easel with the
[ __ ] thing and you're writing the
[ __ ] things down there's wings
there's beer
you know and then you know when someone
drafts like that i just love just just
putting down my best friends it's
actually my favorite thing to do when
they when they pick a bad pick or yeah
what the [ __ ] are you doing or some new
[ __ ] who picks like a kicker in
like the ninth round and i'm like bro
you know you could have just waited
until the end for that
[ __ ] the whole time why do you have
three defenses